okay two matters at hand it's it's my
pleasure to introduce to you Terry Ann
Coulter some of many of you I suspect
know Terry he's currently a professor at
Penn State University and he also earned
his undergraduate degree there several
years back some of you in the audience
will recognize Terry aza is a graduate
student in Yale's department of geology
and geophysics Department where he was
here from 1968 to 1970 before moving to
Texas A&M to finish his ph.d I could
read you a long list of Terry's academic
credentials but I wanted to do something
a little more interesting in that get
some personal information and so when
you're asked her personal information
what do you do you go to Google so I
googled ter all right and I found out
that Terry's been a prime focus of media
attention since 2007 for his work that
he's done in the Marcellus Shale this
attention culminated with Washington
Post foreign policy magazine recognizing
Terry is one of the top 100 global
thinkers and and this is pretty rarefied
air other people on this list include
President Obama
I love Secretary of Secretary of State
Clinton defense secretary gates and also
Britain's Prime Minister David David
Cameron so this recognition in turn led
to an invitation for Terry to attend
Obama's the Obama administration state
luncheon where it was discovered
tongue-in-cheek
that Terry on this top 100 list actually
outranks Prime Minister David Cameron
well alright thank you very much Jim now
is this microphone on and we're all set
I guess the one thing I didn't discover
up here was the clicker how I advanced
this all right now how is that this
microphone is on
maybe maybe what you want to do is turn
that guy off how's that sound
all right this is the one that's the
room mic here and we'll bring this
higher how's that how's that sound okay
all right the old-fashioned way I wanted
one of these things so that means I have
to get out my wand here and and do this
all right thank you very much Jim it's a
pleasure being back here and in fact I
have a lot of very warm memories of Yael
during the two year period of time that
I was there and a couple the faculty
still remember me particularly Carol and
and Brian what I want to do is describe
one memory that neither of these people
were aware of which is that Yale's
premier distance runner you guys might
remember that Frank Shorter
won the gold medal in the marathon in
Munich in 1972 what you didn't know was
that I was a distance runner as well and
that in the IC for a championship of
March of 1967 I ran against Frank Here I
am right here from Penn State there's
Frank right there and this is a
relatively famous photograph back at
Penn State now when Jim introduced me he
made the point that the media first
focused attention on me based on the
calculations that I did for the
Marcellus in 2007
ironically it turns out that Frank
Shorter was the first to recognize me
here he's dated it you can't see the
date right here but it's dated December
13 2007 Frank I think did this because
he recognized
he's been the subject of media attention
for a long time I've known him for a
length of time in fact is one of the
interesting things is that when I came
here as a graduate student he was a year
younger than me that was his senior year
when he was training and it turns out
that there was no one on the Yale track
team that could go through a full
workout with him so I spent weekends for
example going on 20-mile runs with him
and that spring he became the 10,000
meter champ NCAA 10,000 meter champ and
so rather than doing geology on weekends
I was doing this and this is something
that you guys did not know okay so that
media attention I again started in 2007
it was about October 2007 Frank's
signature on that particular race for
Madison Square Garden was sent to me two
months later this it turns out is the
290 fourth talk that I've given in that
period of time I think more
significantly in that period of time I'd
been approached by 424 different
reporters and you might ask how many
reporters has the president been
approached by probably quite a bit less
than that because he doesn't he's not as
busy as I am and the the cumulative
attendance right here is above 20,000
now how do I know that what I do is is I
know that because it's all recorded in a
series of notebooks like this that I've
already had Brian take but if you could
pass that around you'll find right here
on page 98 some people have signed it
actually why don't we go from the left
side pass it back get it through the
audience let Kathy sign it first Brian
so
so this is picked up okay let me let me
get away from that then and this is okay
with you back there all righty
perfect there you go that's that'll take
care of it typical modern talk it just
takes a while with the AV and all of
this other fancy stuff back when I was a
student with Brian you just got up with
a piece of chalk and started talking and
there was it all worked back then okay
so now what what is this fracking
business all about and it's important
probably to draw an analog with the
literature in this case the literature
they draw upon are two relatively famous
books concerning the collapse of
civilization and on the left is taters
book written in the late 1980s in his
hypothesis was that energy capture would
lead to or did lead to the collapse of
civilizations and this is a counter
pointed view written by Jared Diamond
most of you remember that written about
ten years later in his point of view is
no it was the environmental
mismanagement that led to the collapse
of many civilizations so in the fracking
debate that we're talking about right
now
what I want you to do is keep in mind
these two particular different points of
view concerning the collapse of
civilization keep that as an analog so
what we find is that in the debate that
I've had in the literature this is a
fairly well-known paper that was written
about a year ago in nature it's a
point-counterpoint should fracking stop
and one view was yes it's too risky and
the other view is no it's too valuable
both views however it's very important
to appreciate this both views are
fraught with moral ambiguity and you've
got to keep this in mind as well when we
talk about the fracking debate so
the two sides actually represented by
Tony and graffia who argued yes this is
too risky it should stop immediately
I represent the other side right here no
it's too valuable you recognize a
notebook being passed around this
picture actually comes from a talk that
I gave in Czech Republic about a month
ago who has the notebook right now and
if you take the yellow sticky and open
up to that page there are the signatures
of the people that signed this notebook
right off of this talk Tony on the other
hand rather than passing around
notebooks nuzzles up the famous people
you'll recognize yoko ono right here and
other other famous anti frackers so this
is the view and of course you might ask
in this analog who's represented by this
well tony represents the point of jared
diamond which is that the environment is
at risk and that is entirely true i took
the point of view that no it's energy
capture that really is is is the most
immediate now one of the other things i
want to make very clear is that in 2007
long before Frank Shorter sent me that
picture signed by him I had to sit down
and actually go through the process of
saying this is really going to affect
such things as the amount of co2
released in the atmosphere do we really
want to do this this is also going to be
a tremendous help to such things as
American energy security do we really
want to do this this is a balance
between two choices there's no right and
there's no wrong but I don't think any
of us in 2007 fully anticipated the
extent to which this would become
politicized and it is now a public
debate ironically reason I like to show
Tony as Tony and I wrote a paper
together about 15 years ago on hydraulic
fracturing and so I've known Tony for a
long period of time and and one of the
things I have to say is that there is no
more passionate better debater in terms
of defending his point of view
Antonius this guy is brilliant in terms
of his speaking style in his ability to
engage an audience
and a brilliant scientist also so a very
interesting partner in in this
particular business ok now global
thinking how does this how does this
play out here's an interview that I gave
last May in the Czech Republic and I was
interviewed by this science reporter for
the large daily newspaper nice in the
Czech Republic and I was quoted as
saying some Europeans fear the
propaganda and Josh Fox movie Gasland
more than the hand of Vladimir Putin on
the valve that supplies natural gas to
Central Europe now ironically just the
day before yesterday a reporter for the
large French weekly magazine called up
and I tried to get him to quote this
particular quote but replace the word
Vladimir Putin with the word president
of France because in fact the French
have voted to ban hydraulic fracking and
for better or for worse now the point
that that needs to be made is that the
French succeeded in the 1970s in
developing electrical generation
capacity using nuclear power plants
there's no other country in the world
that has the same luxury so in fact the
French president can actually ban
fracking without really affecting the
electricity supply of his nation here's
the actual publication of course it was
in Czech and within 48 hours 42 people
commented on that normalized to the
American population that's 12 hundred
and 60 people this is an exciting thing
for people to write in about in this
this new media all right now the debate
continues and it continues to the point
where Hollywood is going to release a
movie this coming December 28 entitled
promised land this is a Matt Damon movie
and in this movie what you'll see are a
series of dead cows that have sort of
dropped over in northeastern
Pennsylvania this is pure fiction now of
course there was one case in Louisiana
where barbed wire
an open fracking was broken and some
cows decided to drink of that stuff and
did suffer a tummy ache as the result of
this so the point though more
importantly is that this particular
movie is funded by Middle Eastern banks
now why would Middle Eastern banks fund
a Matt Damon movie and it's very simple
which is that there are a couple
countries gutter and the United Arab
Emirates whose total economy is a gas
based economy so that when gas from gas
fields like the Marcellus depress the
global price of natural gas the entire
economy is affected and so these guys
are going to push back as hard as they
can against the North American gas play
and one of the ways you push it back is
you put into the the media a lot of
fiction in fact is this is a little bit
like like gas land now on the other side
of things you'll notice right here facts
funded by the American by an American
business so this is really a global
competition the international business
is pushing back the American business is
funding this now guess how long ago this
happened where Larry Catholics Terry
Engel Durand Fred Baldassare were
standing in this field that picture was
taken less than 24 hours ago in fact is
on my way over here this film crew got
us and they approached us for a couple
of reasons not the least of which is
they said we've got to prepare we
meaning the American businesses have got
to prepare to push back against this
movie which is going to capture the
public and in a way that that sort of
lets this get out of out of control now
a little bit of an explanation here Fred
bola sorry is the PE Pennsylvania DEP
geochemist that was originally assigned
to look at methane migration in the area
of Demick and to look at water chemistry
in the area of Demick it was Fred who
was basically crying out in the
wilderness saying there is no evidence
of frack fluid
endemic area polluting groundwater and
people kept saying no you're you're not
getting this right and what not and it
was only recently when the DEP for a
second time said yeah sorry EPA the
federal EPA for a second time said no
that's that you're not this water hasn't
been polluted now the interesting thing
is that when EPA came out with that the
end of the script for this movie had to
be rewritten because of course it was
going to be a conclusion in which people
were poisoned and people were affected
one way or the other so the movie got
got changed
Larry Catholic is an expert on two-phase
flow through rock and also has been
stating for a long time that in fact
it's a consequence of two-phase flow
that assures that American groundwater
will be protected now I'm going to talk
about my role right in here
as well but in the meantime you see this
right here this again is that that
ever-present notebook that you're
passing around these guys also signed it
and if you want to turn the previous
page you can look at the signatures from
these guys as well so at any rate we
move forward then out why is it that
natural gas has really had an impact on
North America this is the New England
power grid and how its evolved over the
last ten years and one of the
spectacular impacts of natural gas
particularly from the Marcellus on New
England electrical power generation is
that coal-fired power plants supplied 16
percent of all electricity in New
England as little as 10 years ago and
right now that's been reduced to 6
percent and I'm sure that some of you
have heard in the last six months that
EPA has announced that the amount of co2
emissions from American industry is
lower than it has been in a long long
long time mainly as a consequence of
natural gas right here pushing back on
the coal industry this is spectacular
question
there was an epic drop no this is this
is normalized this is a percentage this
is percentage normalized I think moving
in and the end of the future is a fairly
important thing to do with this
particular chart as well because we have
a lot of people who say well that money
that's being spent developing natural
gas should be spent developing
renewables wind and source so we're
going to look into the future of New
England and one of the things you see is
that the future capacity of New England
does include a large component of wind
right in here like this but you'll
notice that for every megawatt of wind
generated electricity there will be a
megawatt of get natural gas generated
electricity and I've made it very clear
which is that wind is not continuous you
have to back it up and in fact as the
carrying capacity average carrying
capacity for wind in the eastern part of
the United States is somewhere on the
order of 7% which basically means it has
to be completely backed up and that's
what this particular projection looks at
right here for New England's future yeah
Jay oh I'm not sure what this is in
terms of a period ahead you'd have to go
back to a NECA to find that out the but
the point the point right here is that
in terms of the renewables they're great
but somehow or another energy has to be
stored and we don't have the battery
capacity of storage capacity to take up
anything that is left open in terms of
generative capacity when things like the
wind doesn't blow alright so that's the
good news
and in fact is I would say that looking
at that when if I had known that this
would be the outcome back in 2007 when I
originally went through this period of
questioning about whether or not talking
about the value of natural gas to North
America relative to its impact on the
environment this is a really positive
outcome that I couldn't have imagined
all right now I there is public concern
in Pennsylvania the Marcellus frac fluid
can mix with groundwater thereby causing
an outbreak of health related problems
among those who drink water we all we
all would agree with that and so the
question is is that true we need to pass
that on to the center section now in
fact is this has been reinforced by the
recent literature this is a publication
in National Academy of Sciences and the
title of this particular article is get
chemical evidence for possible and I
emphasize right here possible natural
migration of Marcellus formation brine
to shallow aquifers this is written by a
series of authors from Duke all right so
that's that's the that's the title of
this paper and you all know what the
word possible means the the problem with
this of course is moving forward into
the popular literature and I would
suggest that this particular magazine
this is the December issue of National
Geographic this arrived in
my house about two weeks ago and if we
look into the December issue of National
Geographic
there is a article entitled fracking for
methane by golly let's see what they
have to say and one of the things we
find here is that the title of the story
is good bad good gas bad gas oh I really
love this picture though which is a
termite termites actually generated a
lot of methane right there termite
captured an amber with methane seeping
out its tail in I don't know how he did
that when he got captured in amber but
that's a beautiful picture there are a
lot of ways that methane gets into the
atmosphere and you all understand of
course that methane is is is is a global
force ER and that some of the debate
over fracking involves the amount of
methane that might leak into the
atmosphere as a result of drilling and
so this is the statement though in
National Geographic that caught my
attention now remember that we have this
possible chemical evidence for possible
migration now that G chemical evidence
is based on an incomplete data set no
consideration was given to the
geological reality in that
interpretation it is an interpretation
but suddenly that interpretation in the
popular media right here gets turned
into a fact
Dook scientists have recently reported
evidence that fluids have migrated
upward from the Marcellus through
natural fractures in the and and in the
groundwater if you read that that paper
so here's an interpretation that all of
us understand now on the public domain
is a is a fact so that that in the
review process there was some pushback
against this this particular paper from
Duke because of the fear that this is
immediately going to be seized upon by
the public misunderstood and turned into
a fact and once the public turns a piece
of science into a fact it is awfully
hard to reverse now the reason that I
say that this was based on an incomplete
data set is found in any type of law
that is produced from the Marcellus so
here's an electrical log it's it's
produced by a slumber Shea this is a
gamma ray log right in here this is a
lithology log you can see the underline
on a dog a limestone right here and
admittedly this is a very very complex
diagram so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to just draw your attention to
this portion of the log right in here a
bearing in mind that most of this is
Marcellus up through here so I'm going
to show you Marcellus right here and
we'll look at this in detail because
this is the crux of the geological
argument used to demonstrate that the
evidence for migration of fluid from the
Marcellus into groundwater is probably
not the correct interpretation and so
let's spend some time looking at this
first of all let's understand the
various plots right in here first of all
the porosity which is shown right in
here from 0 to 4 40% this is actually
intense right in here from 0 to 1
so zero porosity is here 40% porosity
the rock is right there and this dashed
line represents porosity and so what we
see are four components to that porosity
one of the components is clay bound
water in the clay bound water and effect
is this area right in here like this so
that in a slumber je LAN log which is
what this is porosity doesn't mean open
space and rocks it really means that
stuff that's filled by hydrogen this is
largely based on a log that we call a
neutron porosity log so some of it is
clay bound water some of the porosity is
actually bound water you'll notice they
are called the same except that here
bound water means surface bound water
surface bound water basically is the
stuff that when you pour a glass of
water
there's the inside of that glass is
still wet after all the water has been
poured out of it that surface bound
water and that shows up as grey right
here and you can see on a scale that is
a porosity scale that goes from a zero
to 40
there's just very little bound water
right in here like this now the other
two things that are found in this
porosity include a little bit of free
water there's a little bit of free water
right here and a little bit of free
water right here but no free water
anywhere in the major portion of the
Marcellus except for one spot right in
here like this
now remember this Duke paper geochemical
evidence for migration from the
Marcellus that migration has to be in
the form of free water moving out of the
Marcellus the Marcellus is virtually dry
in terms of free water that can actually
migrate outward one other type of one
another component in the porosity the
Marcellus is natural gas
this is methane and what you can see in
this particular portion of the Marcellus
is that as much as 16 percent of the
Marcellus is a is composed of natural
gas right in here this is why the
Marcellus is so rich you have this unit
that's on the order of I don't have a
scale right here this is 100 feet this
is a hundred foot tank that that
encompasses somewhere on the order of
31,000 square miles some number like
that I mean it's a huge number of square
miles a hundred feet thick ten percent
of it is natural gas and it is obtaining
that natural gas that then allows
America to move forward in terms of gas
security for a long period of time yes
another question
yes I I hadn't planned on it but I just
very shortly
ven gosh sampled flow back and I'm going
to talk about flow back in a few minutes
so he did not sample natural fluid he
sampled
the what was the result of the
interaction of water pumped down and
water and and chemistry that basically
is diffusing out now sue Brantley Oh
some of you know sue is a really good
Penn State geochemistry and I sue
Brantley and I are putting together
paper right now that proposes a model by
which you can sell innate flowback water
based on the the chemistry of what is
left when you drive off initial sea
bottom water now remember that that when
the Marcellus was deposited it's sitting
on the sea bottom as a news that
probably has an 80% porosity filled with
seawater that has to be driven off
completely by the process first of all
of compaction and then the maturation
process and this rock gets dried out
during the maturation process which
means you expel in an unbelievable
amount of hydrocarbons from this rock
leaving only only a little bit of gas
behind and during that process in effect
you turn this into a dry rock during
that period of time all right so what
Ben gosh did was measured the chemistry
of the flow back not natural water and
observed that the strontium isotope
ratio of the flowback water resembled
the strontium isotope ratio of water in
water wells and and therefore one must
conclude that this is coming from the
Marcellus now the flaw in this of course
is that there are so many other
formations that are sitting below the
Marcellus including the Oriskany
sandstone and the medina sandstone that
have a huge porosity a huge amount
presently of oilfield
Brian natural brine in in the rock and
there's no doubt that that and they've
measured that chemistry as well that
chemistry matches what's in groundwater
and at least in my mind it is far more
likely you know if we use Occam's razor
it's far more likely that the rock in
the subsurface that contains a huge
amount of free water can be the source
of this stuff in in groundwater not not
the Marcellus which is is now virtually
dry so this is this is the geological
argument right in here it is that this
is a dry Rock
now the Marcellus does contain a lot of
fractures and people have argued well
it's the fractures that allow water to
drain out of the Marcellus let me point
out that this natural gas in the
Marcellus is over-pressured now what
that means is it has a fluid pressure
that exceeds the hydrostatic gradient of
any water that's on top so that if the
Marcellus were leaking water naturally
water has a much higher viscosity than
natural gas and as all of you know if a
fluid is going to leak out of a porous
media it is the low viscosity component
of that porous media that's going to
leak long before the high viscosity
component the point is that all of this
natural gas even if it leaked at the
rate of 1 250 million a year would all
be gone now this this maturation
occurred somewhere between two hundred
seventy million years ago in two hundred
fifty million years ago this rock has
been sealed as a result of capillary
forces for that period of time 250
million years and so over that period if
it didn't leak this gas a very low
viscosity fluid it certainly did not
leak high viscosity water out all that
water was driven out a long long time
ago now the to be honest about the the
duke paper they did say we don't
understand the timescale of this all we
did was we observe a chemistry and flow
back that matches the chemistry in water
therefore we conclude that this water
that is
sampled in the ground right now
groundwater drinking water is somehow or
another related to the Marcellus and
there's so many other geological
explanations for the chemistry of
groundwater that does not require
calling upon anything escaping that
section right there yes well the the
problem though Carl with a lot of that
is that the mass of drilling the
Appalachian Basin is largely shallow oil
sands like the Bradford and the elk and
whatnot and so the Marcellus is less
Swiss cheese than the other formations
that couple well you got to be a little
careful right because the wells that
drill through the Marcellus are drilled
on anticlinal structures for a risk any
gas sand which is now gas storage fields
and what these guys were doing the
Oriskany fields either in central or
western Pennsylvania and what these guys
were doing was sampling groundwater in
eastern Pennsylvania where there's been
virtually no drilling and so what even
even when they mix the data from the
Medina they had had strontium data from
the Medina which sits below the
Marcellus and the Clinton sands as well
as data above from the Bradford in the
elk sands that was all western
Pennsylvania stuff so they were taking
to geochemical samples from two
different regions and mixing it mixing
it together yeah question
No
the reason for that largely is that when
the rock is hydraulically fractured and
the well is produced the pressure
gradient which basically is is the
component of a Darcy's law that really
matters the pressure gradient is an
inward gradient towards the wellbore and
so it's that gradient that actually
drives everything up the wellbore not
outward from the Marcellus through this
capillary seal and upward and even if
some of the hydraulic fractures break
their way through the top of the
Marcellus capillaries seal once flow
back occurs it's all inward toward the
wellbore and then up the well so that
that in a sense further assures that
this stuff doesn't get out of them our
Seles but rather flows up the wellbore
and the important thing about flowing up
the wellbore is that it then can be
managed by proper engineering and which
means putting flow back tanks making
sure there are no surface bills because
a lot of the people that have looked at
that said the real danger is not in the
subsurface flowing by natural pathways
back but rather the management of this
water at the surface as it comes back
either the disposal of it or the
retreating of that water and that's
that's that that is something that can
be supervised by engineers so that with
proper practice that no longer becomes a
problem yeah go ahead yeah please
yeah what happened Carl was that that
that the Academy asked me to write a
commentary but they said you can't
criticize the Duke paper but what's the
point of writing a commentary if I can't
know they rejected my commentary because
I wanted to publish this and what
actually the way this is playing out is
I wrote a letter that was accepted and
I'm not sure where they wrote a comment
on the letter or not do they yeah all
right then that that's actually in the
works by letter has been accepted and
and whatever they wrote back has been
accepted yeah it hasn't been published
yet but it's been accepted but the
problem with that was that was reduced
to 500 words and I couldn't include that
particular figure in the whole thing and
what what for the rest of the audience
science is so much fun
because of course it is open to to
debate in the peer review literature and
obviously Carl is reviewed we revealed
himself I've revealed myself I was the
minority reviewer on his paper that was
for four reviewers I think wasn't it
Carl there's a yeah yeah yeah and the in
Carl was the what do you call that the
handeling handeling editor and whatnot
and of course poor Carl is in a you
shouldn't say poor Carl was like any
editor you know in a situation where you
have a minority opinion and a majority
opinion in the end you just as an editor
I've done this with jgr GSA
tectonophysics you know it's it's just
it's a situation where there's you can't
win and of course the
yeah I don't know what I haven't seen it
you know they they're allowed to respond
it's sort of like like these typical
comments this will be published
elsewhere though we'll get this out into
the open
yeah I guess that that Carl my one
response of course is is that that the
the Proceedings of the National Academy
of Sciences publication is fine if it's
not going to be seized by you know the
public media and then misinterpreted
which these guys really did I mean they
turned it into a fact when there are
other other interpretations that I think
are far more logical and again I have to
emphasize that if all you have is a a
chemical data set and you want to
interpret it then you arrive at what I
think is a fairly logical conclusion
which is which is fine but these guys
failed to incorporate the larger data
set which includes geology and
geophysics as well and that's that's
where we got into a little bit of a tiff
or whatever one wants to call that and
one of the things I want to make clear
is this is not a case of sour grapes on
my part because the truth will
eventually emerge on all of this but it
is a lot of fun and and it's sort of a
pleasure talking about this afterwards
because of course the public in general
doesn't understand quite how this
process works and is willing to seize on
pieces of science that seemed to satisfy
their particular biases and that's
that's sort of how the Marcellus and gas
shale in general is going on in terms of
the polarization of all of this okay I
want to make another point right here
which is that when water is put down
into the Marcellus some of it flows back
and the flow back curved in time now
bear in mind that this is a cartoon the
flow back curve in time for water looks
like this and
gasps looks like this and water of
course comes out of a rock that is water
wet and basically you can't get gas
through poor throats that are water wet
and so that's an important piece of
information to have in terms of
terminology notice that there's a point
in time in which gas production starts
this is known as production water that's
produced right in here a first water
that comes back is called flowback water
and it's a massive amount of water but
when the flow back water comes out
you'll notice gas production is
relatively low and then gradually
increases now in terms of the Hall Worth
paper that came out in in fact is even
in that nature debate that that where I
said yes this is too valuable and they
said no it's too risky in terms of the
environment what those guys are
concerned about is industry capturing
this portion of the natural gas that
comes back with flow back and there
still is some question about the extent
to which industry is doing a good job of
capturing this and a lot of people argue
that most of this is captured it's not
escaping and a hole worth worst-case
scenario is that this this methane right
here is escaping obviously once the well
is on line and it's producing back in
here why engineering assure is that the
gas can be sealed one of the things I
should point out is that in this article
drew Shindell who works with with with
NASA and as an expert on global climate
points out that capturing methane
produced in this manner is not the big
worry in terms of global climate change
it can be engineered to make sure that a
lot of the seals are fixed in in fact is
very early on Richard alley who's a
colleague of mine also said when you
talk about this just point out that
industry can find the leaks and fix them
and the this is not quite as big a
concern as is been made out in the in
the literature all right yeah go ahead
yes that that's correct in fact us thank
you for bringing that up because I do
want to trip back right in here another
another point on this graph that I
didn't emphasize is the water saturation
or gas saturation right in here this
curve right in here which is is water
saturation is in blue right in here and
the curve you'll see goes from 1 to
minus 1 which means that just the left
side of this really matters and in terms
of water saturation in the Marcellus you
can see water saturation is less than
10% here's a little more water right
here where we have free water yeah and
this is gas saturation right here up
above 90% through here and that's what
makes a really good gas shale in fact as
we're learning from places like Poland
that if you have a water saturation that
even approaches 50 percent like this
right here that blocks flow of Marcellus
out of the out of the formation so this
is the and in this water saturation
right here very low water saturation of
course is what makes gas shale possible
and the reason that we call this a dry
Rock it's dry relative to free water
what can you do yeah yeah I I don't know
why they did that but it's a for
plotting convenience all right now I'm
one of the things that I do in a talk is
I present too much information and
variably and I run out of time I do want
to make one more point that it becomes
reasonably important in all of this the
question is this this is a side point
incidentally to the National Geographic
article right in here like this and it
again the popular media captures things
that are just not true in this instance
it's pointed out the DME made a
prediction for unproven reserves in 2011
and
thousand twelve this is cut by 40% now I
can't tell you the number of times I've
had anti drillers shove this back in my
face
you were unconscionably high in your
prediction look at what the USGS has
done and whatnot and the important point
is that the way that gas shale reserves
a calculator really depends on how
they're calculated so the National
Geographic makes the deal we look like
fools natural gas in the Appalachian
Basin has been produced for 40 years or
more
there has been an experience of 40 years
looking at decline curves horizontal
production from the Barnett in Texas
there have been 10 years worth of
decline curves it is it is
extraordinarily disingenuous then to say
that suddenly somewhere in 2011 the do
we through eisa Information Agency
suddenly discovers that oh my gosh these
wells are declining more rapidly than we
thought you know it's just that's that's
that's that's a as as far as I can tell
in insult to that particular agency and
you know again a misrepresentation of
what's going on right in here all right
now the water that's put down in the
well and the flow back basically 80% of
that water will stay in place forever
within the gas shale and right in here
is a table from a number of wells taken
more or less at random throughout the
appellation Marcellus play and what we
can see right here in wells that have
been produced for a long period of time
this one is an anomaly and I think it's
an anomaly because often what happens is
operators will flow back more than one
well into a flowback tank and the data
that is recorded right right here is the
amount that comes out of the flowback
tank
regardless of whether it's one wells or
many wells and on average
from this data set right in here eleven
percent of the injected fluid comes back
and so a lot of people have said over
the years well what about that other
stuff that's down there is that not
leaking back to the surface again going
back to the duke hypothesis that all the
rest of the stuff is somehow or another
gotten out of control and away from the
geological realm and what i'm going to
do is show you in a little bit of time
what two immiscible fluids will do in
this case water and air now you've all
seen these cartoons showing that the
boundary between these two and this
boundary is held high by surface tension
if this is a fluid in air or interfacial
tension if it's two different fluids and
the data that we have on surface tension
or interfacial tension is very clear
right in here mercury for example
against air has a surface tension of 480
Dynes per centimeter obviously water and
in air and methane and water and oil
shown right in here like this are
considerably lower so the common model
for this is shown right in here in the
form of a bubble that sits on a surface
like this this come Beck's surface right
in here is held in place by surface
tension from these molecules now here's
a concave example of surface tension in
in a in a concave manner right here
so we keep track of these two of convex
or concave surface tension there's
another force that governs fluids and
that force is known as wettability and
basically it's the tendency of one fluid
to spread or adhere to the other fluid
so it's a force of an adherence and in
one case we have water on a water wet
surface the water will spread out if
water is on an oil wet surface it will
tend to be dis watch this if we do a
series of relatively simply
Berman's here's tap water for example on
vaseline vaseline is water wet this is
the angle of wettability right here so
this is if this angle is high water to
whatever it's on right in here that
means that we're looking at an oil wet
surface notice the the volume here 33
milliliters and the angle is 105 this is
at 0 minutes now to do a series of
experiments one has to account for a
number of things not the least of which
is what happens if you add to the volume
of that initial bubble and so I've added
to the volume right in here 77 154 231
308 and what happens of course is that
the weight of gravity causes this bubble
to Sag so that that interfacial tension
angle decreases like this now the other
question is what happens with time and
so here is that 77 milliliter or 333
milliliter bubble here as time goes by
and you can see the bubble decreases the
reason that bubble decreases of course
is evaporation does allow this
particular fluid in the components of
that to move through the surface of
tension and into the atmosphere we see
the same thing over a longer period of
time so here is a bubble of 77
microliters over a period of two hundred
and seventeen minutes and just just keep
track of that because now what we're
going to do is look at the effect of
surface tension and the force of
adhesion when you combine these two
that's called capillary pressure and
capillary pressure is really defined by
the height of a column of a liquid right
in here this would be water for example
that has displaced air that follows a
hydrostatic gradient that looks like
this so these are two hydrostatic
gradients and the departure of those two
hydrostatic gradients is a measure of
capillary pressure all right now
capillary pressure does something that
is very
interesting in Iraq itself which is that
it serves as the mechanism for
imbibition so I've taken that previous
experiment which is a capillary tube
turned it on its side and looked at a
poor throat right in here like this and
in this case this is a rock with grains
that are water wet and we have gas
trapped in it and basically by capillary
pressure capillary pressure draws or the
adhesion to these surfaces draws this
water column into that poor throat and
basically prevents gas from flowing out
and this then is the mechanism of
imbibition it's also the mechanism of
capillary seals this is the physical
process that allowed gas to be trapped
in the Marcellus for 250 million years
here's a definition for imbibition which
is a very important statement which is
imbibition is a fluid flow process in
which the saturation the wetting phase
increases alright now keep that in mind
because that has a great deal to do with
what I'm about to say which is that when
we start looking at rocks of different
permeability here's sandstone here's a
gas shale right in here the permeability
of a sandstone is on the order of Mille
Darcys which is reflected by this first
three decades right in here shale has a
permeability of nano Darcys right down
and here like this and it's it's when
dealing with rocks of nano D'Arcy
permeability that one then really has to
become concerned with two-phase flow
that's why I've colored this in blue
whereas sand stones up here with a
fairly high porosity large pore throats
then a single phase flow can explain
what is happening so what we're going to
do is a series of experiments looking at
such things as gas driven hydraulic
fractures these are natural fractures
that propagate under gas drive and the
gas recharge by flow back through the
wall of this particular fracture allows
the fracture to reach
charge and propagate onward now in my
career if I have to identify one paper
that has had an impact on the gas
industry
it was the recognition about twenty
years ago with a graduate student of
mine Ella Cosette that a lot of these
natural fractures particularly in gas
shales were a consequence of maturation
with the production of natural gas now
remember that maturation process is an
endothermic process and usually when you
have an endothermic process that is a
volume increased reaction in that volume
increased reaction leads to high
pressure gas that drives these fluids
now for the all intents and purposes
what we're really concerned with here is
the motion of gas in and out of the wall
of this fracture or fluids for that
matter through that wall in the rate at
which they move through the wall so
we're going to do a series of imbibition
experiments which is that here is one of
those gas fracked
sand joints right in here like this and
I'm going to put a sample of water I'm
going to put 156 microliters of water on
that surface and measure the length of
time that it takes to imbibe that water
and what you can see is that after one
minute and 50 seconds most of that water
is gone this is just like pouring water
on a sponge and it's that speed with
which water moves in and out of sand
layers that allows for the process of
natural hydraulic fracturing above the
Marcellus here's another formation again
we have 154 millilitres here's 77
milliliters you can see that within 17
minutes for this rock right in here it's
slightly less permeable but the the
bubble on the surface is gone here's a
look at a gray shale and what we see
with a gray shale right in here is that
65 minutes have passed before that that
bubble disappears so that we have a very
low permeability Rock right in here
notice the order of magnitude there's
four
five orders of magnitude difference in
permeability between these these
sandstones that I've shown you and this
shale and yet the shale is able to take
up this water in somewhere on the order
of 60 minutes a bear in mind that those
experiments with a water wet surface
Vaseline those cup bubbles consumed
about 200 plus minutes in order to
completely disappear by evaporation so
there is evaporation going on here but
part of it is imbibed all right now the
the the punch line right here is that I
acquired some samples cuttings from the
Marcellus recovered in mid-november
from the bush ik number one well right
about here for example in this
horizontal well this is several thousand
feet below the surface right here as
they were drilling the well they were
back in here all of you have seen
pictures of the the process of drilling
a horizontal well on the Marcellus down
below the surface right in here those
cuttings then very simple experiment
cuttings from the Marcellus these are
the cuttings that that were in the
ground less than then then two weeks ago
and I just put this on here for a
relative scale just so that you can see
what's going on now watch this this is
really slick we have here a gas shale
that has a permeability that is less
than 200 nano Darcys and yet in 85
minutes this rock of less than 200 nano
Darcys it is consumed at least part of
that bubble now bear in mind that part
of it is gone because of evaporation but
what is really interesting in all of
this and let's see does this show up can
you see yeah alright what really is
interesting in this is looking at this
particular slide that area right in
there you want to look at because you
can see after one minute this is
expanded to here three minutes it's here
seven minutes it's here and by 17
minutes do you see the entire bubble is
loaded with it whatever that stuff is
now what is that stuff
it was kerogen brian is the guy that
gets to go out you get a free dinner
tonight Brian if you want to enjoy a
joint Jim alright it any rate yeah what
what is happening is that we have a chip
right here that's capable of sitting on
a desktop holding gas in it virtually
forever and yet when you put water on
that the water is imbibed and as it as
it's imbibed it's driving out the
natural gas from the porous space and
the speed with which this gas can be
driven out is just absolutely amazing
now let me just finish up right here
here's a here's a surface view of the
same thing and you can sure see in this
particular slide the gas bubbles coming
out it's it's it's very very clear now
one last point I always go over the
length of time allotted one last one
last point is is this when a gas well is
drilled there's a period of induced in
Bishan and that induced inhibition
occurs right here now induced imbibition
means that the pressure of the frack
fluid against the wall the fracture is a
lot higher than any fluid pressure
within the fracture so that what you
have is a space that is has a water
saturation of a hundred percent and
water Satch wreck of shale particularly
water saturation one hundred percent
does not produce gas very well the
operators are letting the well sit for a
period of time and this allows the well
to mature to the point that it can then
produce a lot of gas this is a period in
which natural imbibition occurs and
natural imbibition is a consequence of
let's let me go through this natural
imbibition is a consequence of the fact
that capillary entry pressure for a high
water saturation this scale right here
horizontally is a water saturation this
is the capital air
entry pressure so rock next to a
fracture has a fairly low capillary
entry pressure back in the Marcellus
Shale itself where it might have a water
saturation between 110 and 20 percent
capillary entry pressure is a lot higher
so we have a situation that is not in
equilibrium and what has to happen is
that the operators then let this well
sit so that the this state of non
equilibrium between the two capillary
pressures can come to equilibrium and
basically what happens is this is a
period of time in which the water that
basically blocks flow of gas out of the
well can wreak willá-- brate basically
opening up channels so that gas can
escape now
what we find then is that the zone of in
of induced in Bishan is about this wide
right in here like this these
incidentally our natural hydraulic
fractures the way that you would look at
them in rock and another knock I have on
National Geographic is look at how they
drew their fractures compared with the
real world so that someone didn't do
their homework and you know the the the
the view that the public has now is a
cartoon that just has nothing to do with
with reality but that's that's the story
for another day
so here is the zone of induced
inhibition and I've drawn this about to
scale right now these cliffs at T Ganic
Falls this is the Geneseo gas shale our
300 feet tall about the size of natural
of induced hydraulic fractures this is
the zone of imbibition right in here
where water saturation is 100 percent
and the reason that wells are given a
chance to cure is that the water that's
captured next to one of these fractures
then has time to filter out sideways
decrease the water saturation so gas can
flow out of the well and the this
basically is a cartoon of the same thing
now one last point and then I'll quit
which is this gas shales consists of two
components one is a water wet matrix and
the other is an interconnected Network
of oil wet organic matter which is shown
right in here like this
and the only reason that gas shale
produces as effectively as it does is
that the water saturation of the rock
when it is less than about 30 percent
then allows for gas to make its way
through this network of oil wet karagin
matrix out to the the hydraulic fracture
if the karagin was not interconnected as
shown right in here then gas shale would
not work as an economic reservoir some
of the gas shales of the world don't
produce very well and I suspect the
probably the first reason for that is
that the interconnectivity of this oil
wet karagin is not quite as good and
therefore there is less of a chance for
gas to make its way out of the out of
the matrix
okay I'll end with that thought and
continue a discussion with us right here
you